excuse moi on a tous oublié nos cartes
d'identité accepterais-tu vous htv bière
on a fait ça pour moi à ton âge c'est un
rite de passage non ouais regarde cet
étang et pourquoi tu as pensé les
m'amenant segunda recruter converti au
bouddhisme
j'étais con d'attendre aussi longtemps à
prendre ça non non vous lève toi une
petite seconde
j'ai besoin d'un break de moka
cappuccino ont fait la fête
tellement mignonne j'ai tu devrais way
frappe avant d'ouvrir et skoda c'est ma
nouvelle amie tu pourrais prétendre être
ma mère madame ranger votre fille ne
prend pas très au sérieux son avis ça a
l'air intéressant votre travail vous
avez fait quoi comme études
tu devrais venir à mumbai aider à
rentrer chez moi non je t'en prie ta
place est tout près nous
t'étais pas là quand ça va n'a eu son
bébé tu mixes est marraine l'a6 à celle
qui prendra trois cars a déjà entendu
parler de l'histoire de la trentenaire
qui traîne avec des ados non pourquoi
pas moi non plus jamais entendu
arrête j'ai failli me l'a coupé si mon
père
tu pètes avec son père n'ont rien à voir
avec ça et que la ce